did you ever think you
why would you bet on goliath when we got
bet david valuetainment giving values
contagious this world are
[Music]
folks we have a special podcast here for
you
uh we have the former deputy prime
minister of australia which is
uh deputy minute prime minister is a
vice president to us right would that be
the equivalent of a vice president in
the u.s it would indeed it would indeed
yeah so we appreciate you for coming out
obviously uh been uh following
your commentaries specifically last two
years with what's been happening during
covid
uh and and seeing how australia we
always looked at australia as a free
nation you know you're thinking
australia and all of us and like wait a
minute
am i watching this from a movie is this
is this in a movie or is this real
you know some of the stuff wasn't even
believable you thought it was fake but
then you're talking to
some relatives in australia because i'm
a syrian they're like no this is
happening
in a certain region of australia but not
all of it so it's very interesting so
for for folks who are in uh today
you know and you don't know a lot about
what's happened with australian politics
we're looking forward to taking a deep
dive into that today we've got a lot of
different topics we'll get into
obviously
i'm i want to hear your thoughts on uh
one of the greatest speeches ever given
the last few days which uh president joe
biden i don't know if you had a chance
to watch that speech greatest is one
word for it yeah i mean his wife thought
it was the greatest speech of all time
anybody's ever given but it's you know
his wife has to think that right that's
a very it's a loyal way is it like i
gotta give her credit yeah i gotta tell
you to me it was a deeply deeply deeply
troubling speech well i wanna hear why
you think that i won't hear why you
think that we'll get into that and then
the rallies obviously things are getting
close to what's going on with
you know midterms coming up this year we
got some weird events taking place i
want to know your thoughts on police
state fbi's involvement
you know when you were there from 1995 i
want to say to 2004 1999 to o5
if i'm not mistaken when you were the
deputy prime minister the years you were
there what it was like how much it's
changed how much the world politics has
changed
whose allies are australia's allies
today what are some thoughts you have on
the future where politics is going so
if if you just tuned in with us you know
and you were at the vault the last
couple of days four days
a couple of thousand people we had an
incredible party at the house until god
knows what time you guys we didn't get
done until 3 30 for john's 40th birthday
it's true shout out kevin honestly
chad's parliamentary we had a great time
kiyosaki it was a great event but today
we're back at the podcast on labor day
on labor day i
and by the way and then we'll talk later
on as well that uh
you know uh uh
john is now running a podcast as well
what an interesting thing first dave
rubinstein
who's a billionaire decides to start his
own podcast a deputy prime minister of
australia decides to start it's such a
different well barack obama had a
podcast what i'm saying is we're living
such it's so great to be able to hear
from
learn from folks like this so 100 john
once again thanks for coming on if you
don't mind taking a quick minute and
just giving us your background of what
you were doing prior to being a deputy
prime minister to becoming a deputy
prime minister and where you are today
uh well look thanks for being here
really appreciate it i'm a great admirer
of america
i worry about your divisions because you
know we need you the rest of the world
needs you we really need you that's the
first thing i'd say uh i grew up on a
farm northwest new south wales i'm
scottish extraction
uh have always been a farmer my son and
daughter-in-law now run our farm
business i'm they sometimes mutton look
like it today in a suit but i drive the
wheat trucks and i repair things and try
and keep the background going
i was educated in sydney uh master of
arts in history
uh was asked to go into politics didn't
go looking for it thought this is crazy
but people said you think you've got
something to offer which is very kind of
them i ended up in it i had doesn't
happen by the way because this this last
week i'm asking people to go into
politics who ask you
uh that persuade you you to you know
consider actually going into politics
how did that happen two retiring
federal members of parliament
congressmen in your language at the age
of 27 it was pretty precocious of me wow
and i got in there when i was about 31 i
think
uh and then um rose through the ranks
became deputy prime minister
it's a coalition in australia on on what
you would call loosely the republican
side you've got the liberal party
but it doesn't mean liberal in american
terms got it it means sort of classic
conservative stroke
true liberalism with a capital l
and the national party which i led and
when they're in coalition and in
government the national party's leader
becomes the deputy prime minister
so i had 10 years as a cabinet minister
i
was a deputy prime minister for
six years i was there at a pivotal
moment when we realized democracy hadn't
won out that was 9 11. our prime
minister was in
uh washington he's only a mile from
where the plane went into the pentagon i
was acting prime minister back in
australia that's part of my job
i thought though
in 2007 there was an election in
australia i thought i've done my bit
i've got a family i've got other
interests i'll make way for someone else
i don't want to be a career politician
addicted to it for life uh because i
don't think that's a good thing serve
and get out that was the washingtonian
model i think you know
um don't hang about past your use by
date
uh and uh there it is uh married four
kids five grandchildren married four
kids five grandchildren
so if you don't mind going back to the
27 years old when somebody comes up to
you and says
i think you gotta run what was the
they said i i think you gotta run
because dot dot dot is it because the
country needs a leader like you is it
because the way you process issues is it
because you could have a career in it is
it because you can make an impact what
was that conversation like uh well it
originated with me attending a rally
that he was speaking at where he made
three points that i disagreed with and
so i stood up very politely and said i
want to take you to task on all of those
three issues
i don't think you will keep my
generation
loyal to the party
with what our outdated attitudes on
issues that don't matter a lot and i did
it in a reasonably humorous way and
instead of holding it against me
he said i think you've got something to
offer interesting i want to retire
and i wanted to run in my place my jaw
hit the ground i was farming i'd
finished university i was home farming
working with my dad
and what would be very familiar to a lot
of americans you know farming operations
very
big family farm but not a corporate
style thing not that big
um
in those days you know a lot of american
equipment all the same techniques same
crops and i was enjoying that
but did have a sort of burning sense
that
if you want to stand on the sidelines
and criticize the way the generals are
running the war you've got to at least
be prepared to enlist as a private
so i thought all right
very highest man
powerful point the man in the arena yeah
it's a powerful point teddy roosevelt
yes so i thought i'd better have a go
otherwise i'm a bit of a hypocrite
and you see the beauty of democracy is
right from day one you put your hand
yourself in the hands of others so they
make the judgment i say look i this is
what i believe in this is what i pursue
you decide whether you want to go with
me or not and for a long time they did
it still amazes me a bit not sure i
would have gone with me all the time but
others were kind enough to support me
what an approach to take here's what i
stand for do you like it great if you
don't totally get it we move on and you
know go
vote somebody else instead of myself so
australia
for you know most of the listeners here
we have we have a five percent of our
audiences from australia okay that we
have obviously it's in the us but we
have a good size listenership
from australia australia as well for
those that don't know historically
what has
politics been for australia and how much
has it changed recently if it has
uh well australia of course uh same size
of continental usa but only 26 million
people clustered mainly on the eastern
seaboard um
it arose out of of course the
declaration of independence of america
in an obscure way the brits
ostensibly looking for somewhere else to
put their convicts but also looking to
recognize they'd lost
the jewel
and didn't want other european countries
to settle australia so they settled
shortly after your war of independence
and it was given self-governance quite
early the you know the english were
quite enlightened about that we might
complain about them but they weren't bad
actually as these things go
um
and australia became it's a federation
like america not as many states
uh states and territories but uh they
were made a nation by an act of the
british parliament peacefully
co-operatively in 1900 with a monarch or
with a democracy yeah the queen is still
the monarch yeah it's not a republic
so
but we call it a washminster because our
house of representatives is modeled on
the english house of commons the senate
is precisely modeled on your senate
the only trouble is that our senate
really should be more of a house of
review and of wisdom and of elders in my
view people who have had real life
experience it's become just a creature
of the parties
so so the last two years so if we can
let's just get right into it
what what happened the last two years
you know
we were watching some things that you
can't go to work you have to stay at
house you can't even get out if you do
get out people
half the stuff didn't even make any
sense like i was saying earlier that it
was like we're watching a movie a horror
movie
you know like what was that one movie
where you can only get out a certain
time and people can go out and kill per
is it purge what's that one movie where
it's purge right yeah it so what
happened what got to this point is that
how
australia would have typically chosen to
handle a crisis like covet a pandemic
like covet or did politics heavily get
involved in the last couple years it's a
really good question i've done a lot of
thinking about it jordan peterson asked
me on his show the same question and
i sort of
reverted to form a little bit i suppose
and sort of thought the training when
we're in politics is be careful what you
say about your own country outside it
and it wasn't quite tough enough the
reality in australia was as i mentioned
as a federation
what you saw internationally more than
anything else was the city of melbourne
in the state of victoria which is led by
a pretty far left socialist premier
um yeah it was bad and it's still going
on because they arrested and handcuffed
a pregnant lady
for you know doing the wrong thing
in a way that doesn't pass what we would
call the pub test do you have that
expression
uh it means that if you were down at the
pub and you said uh this is what the
government's done to a citizen people
would say that is unacceptable the pub
test yeah like pop test got it like
you're hanging out at the bar drinking
shooting with your buddies and you're
like hey what are your thoughts on this
and everyone's like yeah i don't know
about that mate but here's what troubles
me i'm going to say it even though i'm
in another country i don't know what's
happened to some of the
you know australians were known for
having a bit of a larkin spirit for
being resilient for being tough in the
uh you know my father was involved in
the second world war the north african
desert the first battle of any
significance where the when the nazis
took a back foot step it was there
general rommel against the english
general montgomery my father was
fighting with the australians why do i
mention because rommel wrote in his book
that these
soldiers from australia
are the finest product of the british
empire there are no others like them
they were tough they had initiative they
had resilience they would fight for
freedom
but they expected freedom in return
and i don't quite know what happened i'm
going to say that to you in the
australian psych particularly in
melbourne that's made them give way
to an expertocracy that says we know
what's best for you
and they look like rewarding that father
by reelecting him partly because the
opposition's not strong enough so i
can't give you a full answer but i can
confirm to you it is concerning
the biggest state in australia is new
south wales
where a lot of this idiocy
wasn't as bad
but what it was about uh you know
melbourne a equal biggest city and
that's a true international city that
people were prepared it was the most
locked down city in the world and we now
know that the economic and the cultural
and social costs were worse than the
disease i don't think you could really
argue that point so there was a
difference between what was going on in
new south wales that's where sydney is
right that was there 10 years ago versus
melbourne which is just south of that
right when queensland is just above that
yep perth on the left side most of the
most of the citizenry is on the right
side of the country but there was a
clear difference between what was going
on in melbourne and sydney so melbourne
was the
the centerpiece of the lockdown state is
what you're saying it was the lockdown
capital of the world wow so you would
say melbourne is like more like a
california or a new york for us yeah
okay or maybe even worse than that
way worse well the lockdown capital of
the world
um it is worrying but don't miss this
thing that i'm saying what's happening
because i think it's happening in a lot
of western countries
a lot of citizens see the great american
model was let's get this clear it's
about the individual so the individual
that's your core belief
the the supremacy of the individual
and their beliefs should shape the
culture and values
um which were downstream of the
individual and government was downstream
of the culture
but we're reversing that
we're making ourselves creatures of the
state
and there seems to be something creeping
in the what might be called the
progressive left the
and neo sort of a cult marxist sort of
world where people want
bureaucracies and experts and
expertocracies if i can use that word
that's mangling the english language
isn't it i don't think you're probably
never mangle the english language in
america but
there seems to be this desire for others
to tell us what to do why the why is
that creating such momentum though like
you know i think it's fear i think you
know your american founders got this
right they
you know
if
you've got to defend freedom if you're
not really careful the people will go
will give up their freedoms
for safety
so you've got to explain what real
safety is you've got to explain what
freedom is and we're washing it out of
our culture sorry to interrupt
yeah again like you know
okay so let me ask this question
typically in us like when i lived in
iran how we looked at the u.s right
there was a sect that looked at the u.s
like oh my gosh i can't wait to live
there oh i'm going to walk the streets
i'm going to run into rocky i'm going to
run into tony montana i'm going to run
into this camera like that's i'm going
to run into gremlins i'm going to run
into ghostbusters it's going to be
awesome man going to america right like
that was the dream can't wait
to gremlins in america but then on the
on the flip side of it you would see
some people in the streets you know mad
bad hombre call mark bad ambrica
death upon america death upon america so
there was a major love and then the
media sold america as the devil i mean
it was like the worst thing that ever
happened to the world
was america how dare they let women walk
around
with you know their hair hanging out how
dare they let women wear shorts
and skirts and short leaves shirts and a
little bit of cleavage showing how their
look how what they're doing to their we
would never do such a thing and people
are like confused who do you listen to
how how did or how does australians how
do they look at
america what is america to the typical
citizen of australia it's a really good
question i would think in recent times
as china has become more and more
threatening and they are they've got a
list of 14 demands out against australia
for supposed sins none of which in my
view were sins at all i don't think
australia's changed there i think china
has that has driven australians to a
greater consciousness of the importance
of the alliance
but it's a really important question
because i would say as an australian and
an admirer of america
that
uh we got you know the world needs a
policeman and you want it to be a good
friendly coherent policeman that
believes in freedom which is what
america has done
since the end of the second world war
they've secured
the international architecture that's
kept my region you know the western
pacific safe
made people prosperous including the
chinese themselves
and we're very thankful for that and we
wanted to continue but here's the rub i
can really deeply understand why some
americans say hey you know
we put our blood and our sweat and our
tears and our money into this and just
as you've told us there are some people
who who not only not appreciate it but
seem to hate us for it
and my plea would be to americans as
roosevelt and the 30s understood so well
that for all of its might
america needs a free world and it's
worth defending
uh if we're all to
live in a coherent global environment
and it's under attack at the moment
we're very conscious of that in
australia
so so you know the game of dominoes you
know the first one goes and i'm not
talking about dominoes like you play
dominoes shout out to dylan he's beating
everybody last night he played again
he's doing really good but domino where
you put one down and one drops and boom
everything goes right okay my grandkids
love playing it yeah i mean as a grown
man i like playing it but let's keep it
between us so but uh domino's so you
know
in in the world today
there were many times like in our
barracks we had this one guy that was a
bully okay
but
if nobody was around he would bully
everybody okay
but say i was around and another guy was
around it was two of us if we were
around he was a good guy yeah he
wouldn't take advantage of nobody he
wouldn't bullying because he knew
we
wouldn't allow that because it was just
not cool we didn't like that right okay
you have that feeling in families
you know you have that feeling where a
mom feels protected by maybe a son
because if the son's not around the
father will take you know a be abusive
or vice versa if this father's not
around the kids will take advantage of
mom you'll see it in pubs when you go to
a bar you know there's this typical guy
that's drunk going around but there's
the one guy that he's whooped his ass
three or four times so he knows don't
push your weight around because if you
do that to anybody i'm going to come and
clean so the fact that that one guy is
there who doesn't impose himself but
he's at the bar he's in the family he's
at the military base nobody takes
advantage of others
that being us
how true is that that if u.s goes down
the rest of the world is going to feel
it oh it's absolutely true how could it
be any other way what you have to
realize you say that from australia but
a lot of people in america don't see it
that way you know a lot of people in
america say well you know we keep saying
america's greatest country in the world
how do you know america's not the
greatest country that's becoming a
movement in america
by the woke and some of the professors
yeah and it's just you're sitting here
like what is the matter with you but
from your perspective somebody that's
from australia somebody that got to the
highest level of politics in australia
how do you view u.s on what u.s if u.s
falls how the world's going to feel it
like what would happen say u.s falls
tomorrow who takes advantage of people
next well it could be very ugly indeed
you've got what might be called an arc
of autocracy as a pro a former prime
minister in australia labelled it so
you've got china you've got russia
you've got iran you've got north korea
in particular
and then you've got isis and so forth
and they loathe the idea of western
freedom
is western freedom worth standing up for
we'll ask the people who are so keen to
get to america
they're everywhere the people who want
to get into australia the people who are
trying to get into europe and britain
why do they want to do it because their
lands of opportunity their lands where
you don't feel that the police are going
to knock on your door at 3 o'clock in
the morning and drag you away on
trumped-up
charges and take you to a uyghur
prisoner a concentration camp
these things really
matter and of course what's happened is
that whilst we've been so comfortable
after the second world war in our
western cultures i mean they've been
good years i'm a mid-baby boomer boy did
i pick my parents well i lived in
australia it was a free country a land
of opportunity oh just too young to miss
vietnam i've had none of that so while
i've been feeling fat and lazy and
comfortable i hope i haven't been too
bad but you know what i mean
you've had people who loathe the western
way of life not just externally but
within our own cultures
they know the march of the left through
the institutions the cultural marxism or
neo-marxism i don't see why we should
shy away from using that term because
they don't
saying well
why isn't why aren't the working classes
rising up we need more rushes they're
not doing it it must be the strength of
the institutions in the west the
families the political systems the
community involvement the churches the
courts
so let's undermine their validity and
you see it today in the de-staturing
movement the de-staturing movement when
you stop and think about it looks like
an attack on the sins of the past it's
much more than that the way it plays out
in our kids minds is exactly as it's
meant to you're the inheritors of such a
nightmares culture as frank ferrudi from
england puts it that it's not worth
defending
and maybe those guys have cities who
want to bring it down are right
and that would be my plea we need to
wake up to this what we've got it's not
perfect
but this is the best way to resolve our
differences and when we need to change
let's do it through the political system
where we can manage our disagreements
which is what worries me so much about
your president's recent speech and the
former prisons response to it
so
so you you're concerned also about the
formers respond to it so please unpack
that
um first goal would biden and go to
trump i've been in politics i know the
game okay and in your case it's a
slightly different australia because we
have compulsory voting but i reckon
can i be blunt
i don't want to insult your country or
your country people but what it looked
like to me let me put it that way and
someone can push back if i'm wrong or if
i'm being insulting was it your
president
with pole backing
touched the lines that he thought might
bring his voter base out
but in so doing he really took a slash
at all those people who've already been
described as irredeemables and as uh
deplorables
now hang on that's that's
tens of millions of americans
they're not all irredeemable uh and uh
deplorable people a lot of them are the
people we just talked about covered who
who grew the food
and who took it to market and who
processed it and brought it to your food
your door risking their own health they
were the muscle if you like that kept
the place going that we forget about
the commander-in-chief's job should be
to be a unifier to reach out to lead to
say if you're dissatisfied with our
system if you're unhappy with it sit
down and talk to me and explain why and
we'll try and understand our common
humanity so we can pull together again
and rebuild a coherent society that's
why it worried me so much
and then of course it invites an
incredible response insane what have you
so
what message does this send to our kids
about the way that you relate to one
another when you've got a difference
what does it say about what real
leadership is
you know henry ford ii
from this country the car making family
once gave additional definition of
leadership you know you've got to have a
vision
one you've got to be able to explain it
to others so they know what the vision
is to thirdly you've got to have about
yourself the personal qualities to make
them want to work with you to make that
vision real
i reckon that's a pretty good definition
well what is the vision
and you know and how are you explaining
it and is it inspiring people to work
with you to achieve it or is it an
inspiring division and loathing of
anyone you disagree with well who's the
last guy here that unified anyways
who's the last president that was a
unifier that brought both parties
together that's probably a better
question for americans i admire many of
you i mean you think of a truman david
mcculloch wrote the most when i get a
lot of young people who come to me and
they say i'm interested in politics and
most of them i say forget it because
you're about yourself
i don't use that blunt language but the
really outstanding ones i say go and
read one of the books i always recommend
is david mccullough's book on truman
great big thick tone he was a guy he
left with office with the lowest
approval ratings of any president
leading office that we know of we look
back on it now and know that he was one
of the great presidents of all times
i think the thing with approval ratings
is it's also
what's happening in that moment meaning
after 9 11 george w bush's approval
ratings were
sky high
i mean to get to 50 at this point in
america i don't know is in australia is
an anomaly 50
i don't know if trump ever hit 50 i
don't think biden's ever hit 50 much
less 51 i think george w bush at one
point was in the high 70s
um unfortunately it was on the heels of
911.
um but i i mean i've been saying that
for two years now i would love for
somebody to be at the executive office
who can get 60 in this country i've been
saying that for a few years now i just
don't know who that is but that means
adam you've got to drag people over from
the other side correct you've got you
need to convert hey you're a leader
you're not slamming me because i have a
different view you're not slamming me
because i voted for trump because i felt
shut out correct
you're actually reaching out and you're
saying hey can we have a conversation
in australia i don't know what's
happened here but
uh one of our better universities has
been tracking confidence in the
political system and democracy now since
1970.
a staggeringly low number of australians
have confidence that our democracy is
working properly if you don't trust
at the system
in fact if you it's bad enough not to
trust the people in it at any given
point in time if you no longer trust the
institutions that's really serious
if you don't even believe in understand
and trust the principles behind the
institutions
of freedom then you really are in
trouble so trust is critically important
you don't build trust by calling people
names
that's my perspective can you zoom in a
little bit on that can we zoom in a
little bit a public trust in the
government since 19 what what years
after
58 58 so so high was who eisenhower
kennedy and then from there it's just
gone down johnson that was a good drop
off nixon
massive drop-off ford flat carter drop
reagan came up
uh as you can see
right at george w bush right at 9 11.
right now no that's cool that's senior
no oh you're talking here yeah right
there yeah that was the peak moment what
year was that that was 2012
2000 right after 9 11. so clinton goes
up and then since george w bush drops
obama drops yes trump goes up
trump's the only guy that goes up for
man it's not even a go up but he goes up
in the last uh
two years and then you have biden is a
slight coming down and what are the
numbers though because it's hard to hear
25 percent 20
yeah right when's the last time it was
even near 50.
uh bush george w bush yeah and what was
that two thousand two thousand one okay
that's in the heels
here's the thing you make a good point
if you go to that you know last time
that last time it hit 60 percent whoo
look at the last i made six that's 60
and 01 right 9 11. the last priority of
that the last time i had 60 percent was
1970 nixon right
that's interesting so but this is it
proves your point when's the last time
that this happened so so if you look at
the drop off look at clinton how he was
right clinton went up
he was so essentially clinton
this is after the midterms this is after
newt gingrich's compact with america
this was after the republicans took back
congress the house and the senate this
was not at the beginning of clinton's
term this is after he technically
reached across the aisle and got the
change of
uh party in the house and and the senate
well gingrich was man of the year what
94. i thought again time magazine man of
the year it was 94 so that goes back
in the early stages because gingrich
economy wise he's the guy i mean he
brought the economy to
where was that but even still they were
able to work together the two guys were
able to work together well
gingrich was one of those guys that is
sort of responsible for how divisive
politics is now he when he was going
after clinton
the part the part that i would i would
like going back to the conversation
we're having to say
we need a vision
then you sell it then hey get people to
buy in
okay but to be a unifier to like in ufc
like this is almost i'm wondering if
this is the playbook that everybody has
to use
or it's been like this the entire time
in ufc okay
usman may be a great fighter he's not a
good promoter okay
you know
you got these guys that are great
fighters who are the best at what they
do but they're terrible at promoting
right conor maybe wasn't the best the
whole incredible promoter right
so you know mayweather was a great
fighter and he was a great promoter
guess what he got paid the most in the
history of boxing right because you know
how to do more are we at a phase but
it's all about show and less about
politics
is this more showmanship is this more
about just winning your base and maybe
converting a few independents and you're
going gonna get elected is that what
it's become like do people do americans
care less about politics and they care
more about who the enemy is and who can
scare better and who can
you know sell the dream better
i wonder because
how much do people actually sit there
and say what policy is the best policy
today or is it the fact that the guys
don't know how to sell the best policies
i don't know i'm not in that world it's
your world
well i'm out of it now but uh you know
i'm a very keen observer of it uh we've
got to be realistic too so it's not all
the politicians fault not alone we were
talking earlier about cultural malaise
about the march of the left undermining
our institutions deliberately trying to
destroy the ideas behind i mean you've
got this whole what are the 16 um what's
it called the the the new theory about
the settlement of america and its
origins
1619. yeah the 1619 project and it's all
seems to me to be an attack on your real
history so that young people
end up with a very distorted idea or
they're a blank sheet and they're very
cynical i think that's a a big worry so
we've been in our associated state
because life's been so good we've almost
got the idea we can do away with
suffering we can solve every problem
whereas real freedom demands that you're
you know you're vigilant all the time
and you believe in your ideals and you
defend them and you try and make certain
that government is downstream of culture
so that it responds to us we don't
respond to it
but the other thing that i would note is
that americans have traditionally always
revered at least the office of president
and that was a very it shows up in that
chart
um and the president was there even if
he didn't vote for that particular
president he was our president he was a
president of our republic i i understand
from my history this has been a very
deep thing in australia
and in some ways i think it was senator
fulbright pretty legendary figure right
around the world not just in this
country but he made the point this is
where i think you know
cheap attacks that are not based in
evidence that are unfair
um can do so much damage you made a very
telling point he said that um
um
president roosevelt misled the american
people in pursuit of a high ideal he was
referring to
um
roosevelt
putting a bit of spin on something the
germans are doing him this is fdr you're
talking about fdr fdr yeah but he misled
the american people because he was
trying to get america into the war he
believed only america had saved the
world for freedom uh he misled the
american people in pursuit of a noble
objective
thereby opening the door for president
johnson
to mislead the american people in
relation to vietnam in pursuit of
selfish
ideals
and i think that was a pretty
interesting point it was he was
referring to this sort of because you
can see in that chart that re reverence
that americans had for the the highest
office in the land for so many decades
and look at the culmination of that now
for the past few presidents the you said
this is our president this is our
president
the the the thing that people have been
screaming for the last decade or so is
not my president yeah not my president
yeah and that's on the left and the
right whether it's trump or biden or
even obama
sad reality is guys this is the
president of the united states so my
humble place is as a i suppose somebody
from the anglophile as we would call it
the the the five eyes countries the the
english-speaking democracies they share
all their
the five eyes refers to the fact that
they all share the deepest military
intelligence so it's america
britain canada australia new zealand
um that the plea would be that we need
and long for a coherent america
for your sakes
um because i admire you that's i say but
also because the world needs a good cop
in very dangerous times your enemies are
not your fellow americans surely they're
the people who want to destroy your
great experiment in freedom thank you
for bringing that up because that was
actually going to be my next question is
um
who is australia's enemy because it's in
america today i have so many
conversations with people on the left
and on the right and i'm very in the
middle
people on the right will say and i have
one friend in particular he's probably
listening right now he's like
the democrats the left that is my enemy
and there's pete and i'm like really
your fellow american is your man because
you have people calling for civil war
these days out loud okay and then you
have people on the left saying if you're
maga if you're a trump guy
no way can i stand with you you're
un-american you're attacking democracy
so this concept of your of your
fellow american being your enemy when
clearly the enemy needs to be focused on
all the names you mentioned before the
china the russia the north korea the
iran all these guys
how do australians process it who's your
enemy uh we've got the same problem
we've had a recent federal election
where you know miami was the other guy
politically no hang on it doesn't matter
if you're in australia it doesn't matter
what gender you are what pronoun you put
in front of your name what state you
come from you know the color of your
skin whether you're wealthy or rich
actually you're firstly an australian
and you've got a joint interest in
keeping the place if you're like safe
for democracy where there's prosperity
there's opportunity for your kids where
you're not going to be hauled off in the
middle of the night there's no fellow
australian serious australian that wants
to do that to you i mean obviously i
think there are direct parallels here
with your society
but there are people who are amassing
massive military capacity around the
world who would do anything to take
those things from you i don't care about
your internal wars
we've got a brilliant fellow in
australia and i wish i could remember
more detail but his name's tim dixon he
worked for a former prime minister on
the other side to me
and he's been working with a group of
people and they've been studying
relationships around the world and he
said to me that they've
their research indicates that in this
country you can have a bunch of wealthy
republicans and a bunch of well-to-do
democrats mind you most of the money
seems to be on the democrat side these
sides particularly with new tech
millionaire billionaires and things
but the antipathy is of a similar level
to that that exists in the gaza strip in
the middle east
um
you know the antipathy towards a fellow
americans have a different political
persuasion is so deep but it's of that
level but by contrast he said you go out
into the midwest and find a republican
farm boy and a republic and a democrat
farm boy and they get along fine just
like they would have in the old days
and they josh about their differences
they might even have a fierce argument
about them but they don't reduce it to
personal attacks and hatred correct
that's and i think that's the problem in
america today is that you're taking
ideology or
philosophies and making it personal well
i hate you because you support so-and-so
it's like can we get back to the point
where we're debating ideas not
personalities and i think that's a
problem in america too but wait a minute
fine you're saying that but at the same
time
we know which ideas do better
but the better ideas are not winning
it depends on which ideas you're
referring so okay so okay okay so go for
it so go through politics go through
issues be specific
uh
be specific go what is she want to go
with what does you want to go you want
to go up taxes can i throw one in from
go for it uh he's a blunt reality when
it comes to budget management and and
the proper management of the economy is
a highly moral thing because it directly
influences opportunities your capacity
to help those who are not doing well
your freedoms everything depends on a
strong economy
and
[Music]
i'll assert it i can't think
of a
team of
non-conservatives who have ever run the
budget terribly well
well in america i think it's an exact
same thing it's your point well
if you want to debate ideas all right
how did trickle-down economics work
under reagan from what i recall not well
i could be wrong
correct me if i'm wrong but the last
time that we balanced the budget
was under bill clinton a democrat and
you know the famous james carville quote
is tell me what you didn't like about
ray uh clinton the peace or the
prosperity so the next whose policies
were they those are bill clinton's
policies
moderate democrat but know who was
handling who was handling the economy at
that time you're saying he did it all by
himself without the help of newt and
others i'm not saying but well if you
want to start going down the the line of
who was in charge yeah we can go that
route but at the end of the day doesn't
the job fall on the president and you're
saying reagan's politics didn't work i'm
sorry trickle down economics didn't work
what part of trickle down didn't work
you peop just because people say that
doesn't mean that's true right so when
you say trickle down didn't work explain
like say that but give us a little bit
more depth in it well the whole thing on
trickle-down economics is the fact that
the it's it's what the concept
essentially has been lambasted since
that it did not work but but no no but
who said that i'm asking you that's is
this your opinion or is this what others
are well look at his favorability
ratings they tumbled towards the end of
his presence in your question logically
explain to me why trickle i was seven
years old at the time so i can't go into
in depth about that ronald reagan but
then that's the problem then then the
problem is we keep repeating what we're
being told without questioning what
we're being told and doing we're being a
little lazy okay so let's go to the
trump tax cuts let's talk recent memory
then okay okay
the the problem with republicans today
is that they stood for the party of low
taxes lower the deficit balance the
budget okay here comes trump we've added
trillions on to the deficit because of
trump yes there were some tax numbers
they favored the wealthy that's great
i'm not in faith
i'm not in favor of more taxes but it's
not like that worked out well for the
balance budget like for example what's
this lady's name jean-pierre what's her
last name karine creature and jean jump
here she's like yeah let's look at what
the prior administration did the prior
administration locked down kids from
going to school
she's saying this with a straight face
yesterday i'm listening to him like wait
wait who locked down
who locked down kids from going to
school what the hell are you talking
about
but wait a minute and then you have
biden gets up and biden says
we don't believe in defunding the police
how can republicans not protect the
police and the fbi what what are you
talking about year and a half ago you're
talking about defunding the police may
be a good idea so it's so much
gaslighting
that people are just going
yeah yeah that's that's exactly what it
is the 200 billion dollar um
what do you call it the a program that
they came out with for the kids the
rescue plan that they came up with 200
billion dollars yeah 200 billion
fantastic rescue plan that's what we did
we're trying to help these kids only 12
was spent
there's the other
170 billion 180 billion dollars is
sitting in the account doing nothing
only 12 percent was like you really care
about the stuff so if you go back and
think basic principles basic principles
policies taxes if we keep just repeating
what other people say trickle-down
economics didn't work and then we say
yeah trickle-down economics they don't
tell me why it didn't work well tell me
why it worked no no since you brought it
up you got to defend yourself i don't
need to you made the argument i didn't
bring up trickle-down economics you
brought it up so tell me defend why you
didn't work tell us
listen i'm not going to start defending
or no no but what you're putting okay
how about this yeah would you agree that
in the
nomenclature out there trickle-down
economics didn't work no that's
something that people read i disagree i
i disagree with you i feel like that is
the thing that people talk about but i
can give my argument you need to give
your argument okay then i'll admit that
i don't have a nuanced approach to this
other than the fact that i know that it
quote-unquote yeah didn't work yeah like
for example this might be a
controversial topic i wasn't around
during civil rights i wasn't around
during slavery but i'm gonna go on the
record that that stuff didn't work well
i didn't have to be there to in order to
describe it a couple of observations
from the other side of the pond about
the reagan years it came in after carter
when the american economy was on his
knees by the time he left the american
economy was much stronger more
significantly
officer slogan it's morning in america
again um
you know you had the collapse of
communism the wall came down mr
gorbachev tear down that wall and the
wall came down
and actually that lies in some ways at
the part of the problem i think we went
to sleep we thought democracies won out
you know and and democracy seemed to be
on the march so i would say that you
know there's a plus side there and in
relation to trump before covert it's
worth noting because that's not
economics
it is part of it but it's not social
economics no no no no no no hang on i i
would argue that the sheer strength of
the american economy which the russians
couldn't match
was the undoing
of that autocratic regime and its
collapse it was the strength of this
economy that's pretty powerful that's a
massive blow for freedom
and in relation to the trump views pro
but until covert started
what you actually saw because this
country this incredibly wealthy country
every time i come here i'm reminded of
it you know they're magnificent
buildings and
anyway i could go on and on but you had
flatlining real wages living standards
had only been rising because people had
gone deeper and deeper into debt you can
chart all that out that was starting to
reverse you had higher levels of
employment and real wages were starting
to rise again in this country
now i don't know where you go post
covert and in terms of the policies of
the current administration but to be
fair to the trump era you could chart
all of that out
you know more people had jobs and real
wages were starting to rise again
and i think that's a big thing in an age
where i'll tell you what really worries
me now is the astonishing concentration
of wealth in the western world but
particularly in your country astonishing
accumulation of wealth in fewer and
fewer hands you've got the tech
squillionaires
who now have enormous influence over
government policy while many americans
are saying hang on we're going back to
these days of declining living standards
really falling real wages we've got the
same problem in australia you're not
unique and that really worries me
economically and socially and i don't
think you can actually separate the two
don't know
the um that's just uh especially from
the other side of the point that's great
but you're making the parallel between
australia and america is basically
australia a um a mirror of what's going
on in in the states i think it's common
to all western countries and i really
despair the lack of focus on repairing
budgets
uh you know we could face a serious
global food problem particularly if the
iranian situations you know
they're starting to export grain at the
moment you're saying ukrainian ukrainian
okay
because russia and ukraine are major
wheat traders mm-hmm um i think post
comments
country exporter in the world i want to
say uh number five
is number six yeah wow uh china believe
it or not it's a very big exporter it's
funny how the world works out but uh the
point is that i don't know how many the
next crop might be a different matter
they might be able to say but we may
face a global food security issue of
very big proportions
that will be an another international
shock how a country is going to cope
i've just been to a conference in
canberra which i chaired where we were
talking about this because most
economies
are so
deeply indebted
and no one's talking about putting some
shots back in the locker no one's
talking about budget repair
no one's grappling meaningfully with
saying you know we are going to wipe our
kids off the face of the earth if we
don't do something to get our economies
back in order and if there's another
there'll be another pandemic we want you
know we haven't got the resources to
help with it in the way that we did in
the past and you americans thankfully
are investing heavily in the ukrainian
situation you're putting a lot of stuff
in there you think that's a good thing
for us to continually just throw
billions at ukraine
you can't it's inconceivable we let the
other side walk all over you the ukraine
that will be so dangerous for global
stability and peace it'll be terrible so
you are an advocate that america does
get involved and even more involved in
what's going on in ukraine
i i don't want to tell you how to do it
no but i mean you have an opinion but
well you're putting a lot of resources
in and i admire that determination and
the west has shown it's still some unity
that must be sending a clear signal to
beijing
you know we do still have some strong
beliefs in in you know in freedom and
democracy and what have you but it's
costing us
it's costing a lot then you've got china
or germany of course it's pumping still
pumping because of bad policy i would
say more money into the russian economy
than it is into assisting the ukrainians
withstand that why because it needs its
cows yeah well they've set up a you know
very high policy was they were
unrealistic this is one of the great
problems naivety
we didn't stand up when the chinese
started uh taking over those islands
you know we didn't stand up in the
middle east red lines all that stuff oh
they're nice guys they'll come to their
senses yeah well that's what they said
about adolf hitler there's some people
who only understand strength and
resolution
and i know you know i want to say i mean
i actually think the americans again
have led on this
they're putting up the bulk of resorts
the brits have been good we've done our
bit we actually really have we've
stepped up a long way away but we've
tried we're putting stuff in there
yeah these things really matter i don't
know
i'm not i'm not sure i'm fully convinced
sending money to ukraine is a good idea
and i think maybe they don't have a
choice right now that they have to do
that but i think there was a different
way
of handling that situation because all
it's doing is
you're unifying iran ukraine and iran
russia and china
and the closer they get and they unify
against u.s i mean u.s is in trouble if
they do that a lot of people are in
trouble if they do that so and ukraine
is uh
you know he's he's done a great job
become this heroic figure but at the
same time
not comfortable with all of it you're
saying zielinski i'm a little i'm not
comfortable with all of it i mean i
understand ben stiller thinks he's the
you know hero or whatever but
you know
i'm just i'm just not comfortable with
it it's like hey this is not enough you
need to send us more money hey this is
not enough i'm just not comfortable with
that makes me very uncomfortable
with the way he's uh
raising money and you know asking people
to send money and then he's doing a
photo shoot for what was the one that he
did a photo
are you saying that it's a sense of
entitlement yeah i'm not comfortable
with it because the reality of it is
listen
so
you know again this goes back to
leadership
if the right strong personality is there
the other guy doesn't bully goes back to
the same exact example i gave 20 minutes
ago when there's that one person in the
family and he dies people get bullied
and taken advantage of in that family
when there's this one guy at the bar
that
he just shows up and the place is quiet
no one messes with anybody they just
have a good time and then he leaves then
bullies show up and abuse others yes
i think
nobody in the world is intimidated by
bite nobody is
and his
horrible foreign policies without
showing any strength on the way he
handled afghanistan just opened it up
and said listen if we're ever going to
go after ukraine this is the time to do
it
uh so anyways we've already talked about
that many times i'm not convinced the
solution
look i'm in the insurance business what
is the insurance business risk no the
insurance business it is risk yes but
the insurance business is about don't
buy the product after you have cancer
don't buy the product after you have a
heart attack don't buy the product the
best part about insurance is buy it
early and keep it insurance companies
make money because people cancel their
policies if you keep your insurance
policies insurance companies don't make
money so it's more preventative right
yeah i'm going to tell you what you're
saying but then you've got a bully
called mr putin as well i i understand
and the bully wouldn't be a bully if
america had a leader that knew how to
stood up stand up and be strong the
bully only can bully because there's not
somebody else
that says hey knock it off so
putin is not in putin doesn't wake up in
the morning of going to sleep thinking
about biden he doesn't think about that
and and you know how certain people in
life they threaten there are certain
people you're not worried about their
threat
if if joe biden right now said john say
something i'm going to whoop your ass
what would you do yeah exactly so you
don't sound like there is no weight
behind his words and i i don't think we
can handle anything you think he went to
sleep worrying about trump
putin
100
yeah he was unpredictable 100 percent he
had he's through the china he's a 1
million percent yeah but so vladimir
putin may be a bully but he's a pest
he's a pest he's not a threat xi jinping
is a threat and all we're doing right
now is throwing resources at ukraine
we're running out of the us army is
running out of ammunition like we are
not going to be able to defend ourselves
should we have to against the threat of
judgment and this is not like well and
ukraine isn't like we're going out to
defend japan or taiwan or hong kong i
mean ukraine has always been one of the
most corrupt countries in the world so
yes while vladimir putin may be a bully
all we're doing is driving him into the
arms of xi jinping and and i think it's
worth to think of vladimir putin as a
joseph stalin while joseph stalin wasn't
some hero in the world we we won world
war ii because of because of the
russians and oliver stone pointed this
out if we didn't have the red army to
stand up against germany and how
powerful germany was we would have never
won world war ii we would have never won
this out so i i think it's very
uh it's not very beneficial for us to
be throwing billions and billions and
billions of dollars at ukraine
especially when all we're doing is
driving vladimir putin into jesus i i
got to say to you i understand what
you're driving at it is a real problem
and again uh the worst offenders
let's be honest about this is not
actually the americans in that regard
nato you know really essentially as
trump was pointing out bludging on you
guys
and not spending enough on defense and
then it all goes to custard hey we're
the americans you know we need we can't
live without you
um and you know and my own country has
has has not been active enough we've
been spending about two percent of gdp
on defence we we've not you know we've
always wanted to hide under your
umbrella
but to pick up what you're saying i
think there's a fair bit of wisdom in
just
history's always a great teacher isn't
it you think the end of the second world
war the allies squeezed the german pip
until uh orange until the pips squeaked
as they put it they just
nailed under the floor
and
look at the results after the second
world war i'm just
i think you know if you want to talk
global leadership you want to talk
insurance you want to talk compassion
you want to talk doing the right thing
think of what the americans did
with macarthur in the lead in japan and
japan now is a major
force for good in the world i would
argue it's a democratic country uh it
it's cooperative it's it's a great
partner and an ally
you think of what happened in europe
this country had a horrendous debt after
the second world war they turned around
found another 13 billion dollars for the
marshall plan
europe wouldn't exist it wouldn't have
been it it was it was in a worse mess
when they introduced the marshall plan
than it had been at the end of the
second world war economy shocked kids
starving just an absolute mess and the
americans displayed leadership and
wisdom
and maybe a big part of what we need to
recognize in the west is that
after the berlin wall came down we kind
of left them all to it so the russians
actually tried democracy for a few years
and they couldn't make it work under
boris yeltsin yeah and and where was
europe where where were we all
in helping them through that difficult
period where they became so cynical they
said give us back some water
and democracy collapsed and they
embraced mr putin because he gave him
back some order you know there was a
downside a lot of serious downsides we
gave them back some water they felt safe
in their beds at night again
but history is a valuable guide and i
one of the reasons i admire your country
so much is because well you saved
australia during the second world war
but you also gave us an architecture
afterwards
that advanced democracy and made the
western pacific prosperous region
you brought up uh japan right there and
like what they were able to do um and
you obviously were referring to china
uh and since you're australian or united
states i think it's a perfect segue into
this concept of this quad this quad
alliance between
australia india
japan and united states in the
indo-pacific region yep uh what are your
thoughts on this alliance uh i think
it's a very good i think it's a good one
lee kuan yew a great statesman from that
tiny little singapore he warned over 20
years ago what was coming
and he said he actually his perspective
was the chinese may never have to fire a
shot they just squeeze their economic
muscles and everybody will toe in but he
said
unless
nations that are committed to freedom
combined together
you know there'll be no way to hold this
juggernaut and i think that's right
japan has moved a lot shinzo abe who was
assassinated i mean the most
extraordinary thing for that to happen
only a few months ago he was a i
actually knew him he was a great and a
fine man yeah we met before we were
serious office holders and he told me
how much he respected australia because
he told me the story
uh that uh as a young man he'd not known
what japan had really done in china in
the 30s and then right throughout asia
you know
they were they were not told at school
he said i went to australia and i
started to understand that we had not
behaved as honorably as we're told and i
started to understand that australia and
the west had behaved very honourably and
then when i discovered that the famous
submariners [ __ ] submariners who were
killed in sydney harbour in a raid in
1942 had been given military funerals
because the australian military said we
will set the standard
you know
they were obeying orders
um they were doing their country's
bidding we would expect the japanese to
respect our dead service people men and
women so we will give them a military
funeral as controversial and he said at
that point i came to realise that we had
behaved dishonorably you had behaved
honorably he was paying tribute to
western values at that time i'm not
saying we're perfect i don't want to sit
here and say we're perfect
but i just want to say that history
shows us at our high points we've got
things right your point about firing off
too many shots now is really worrying
because you've got so many trouble spots
around the world today
the british military used to say that
needed when in empire days which i know
americans hate as a concept and you know
the americans were always having a go
church all over it
um but the the brits used to say they
had to be able to maintain two battles
and one major ones and one minor one at
any given time
and and that goes to your point what
could the american military really cope
with even with all their allies on board
if
a really serious problem well i guess
we've got one now but if others start to
think he's our opportunity we'll go for
it now that is a real danger and we
truly need statesmen and women to lead
us through it we really do
hey pat you um that alliance that we're
talking about with john here america
australia japan india
um my question is about india i think
population-wise you said 25 million in
australia yeah i think in japan it's uh
a little over 100 million 125 million
here in the united states 300 million
india 1.4 billion people yeah right i
mean that's not i mean they're them in
china are neck and neck as far as world
population and i know you have strong
thoughts on uh where india's role is and
how young they are versus china's age
what do you what do you say about that
path all i'm all i'm uh
hopeful of is the right philosophy
winning and advancing
the india is the one country that does
not trust china at all
and china doesn't like it's a past to
china
but if they're willing to stay that
strong against china the world is a
safer place
if india
their philosophy shifts into what china
believes in and they become united the
world is going to be in deep trouble if
those two guys unite
very problematic the fact that these
guys stand up to china
makes the world a better place but
that's a completely different
conversation
but it's part of it with this whole quad
concept
we now have orcas too where america and
britain have agreed to share nuclear
technology and ultimately nuclear
submarines with australia i mean i don't
want to
go on a limb here but it seems to be
it's the good guys versus the bad guys
okay
the the five eyes that you talked about
right
the uk great britain united states
australia canada eu democracies
everyone and then it's
china russia iran sort of totalitarian
states if you will that seems to be and
then india
think they're on our team
pretty sure they're a democracy right
in the end
at the end of the day i mean
why would the world allow a china to
take over because we self-doubt
neil ferguson makes a point i asked him
a few years ago in one of my podcasts
what are the three greatest threats to
our freedom he said first islamic
extremism
islamic extremism number one no no three
sorry in ascending order okay gotcha uh
second misadventure between the super
power and the rising super power
miscalculation well that's what we're
talking about but the greatest is that
we don't believe our history our values
we've rejected them we've undermined our
own confidence in our own model and this
is the amazing thing this is why it's so
brilliant to hear your perspectives
as somebody who you know you see the
flaws you see the weaknesses but you see
the value and the opportunity for us to
flourish as human beings
i can flourish in my own country now
even if the society's becoming less and
less coherent the politics is breaking
down but if we're not careful our kids
in 20 years time won't be able to
yeah so for me sometimes uh um the the
kids and grandkids like when they talk
about how many generations does billion
billionaires wealth last right three
generations later the money disappears
not because the original guy that
created it the founder
he knows how much work it takes to make
the money right the guy that made it
made it
then the kids they got a glimpse of what
daddy or mommy the price they paid so
they get the first hand training yeah
here's what dad had to do grandkids have
no clue what it took
and great grandkids have no clue what it
took you're hoping somebody wants to
pass down the
legacy and continue it
and someone has to keep teaching it and
not compromise the values and principles
it's very very hard to stay disciplined
and keep high standards when you're rich
and you can buy everything and life can
be very easy it's a very
very hard to say no to your kids to say
no to
things that we don't need to spend money
on what's the big deal it's just a
thousand bucks what's the big deal it's
just 500 bucks what's the big deal it's
just 200 bucks i think america right now
is becoming that unfortunately it's
they're no longer
standing up to saying no hey can you
send us more things american people no
can can we can we spend more money on
this no
can we go
no
it's the great great great grandkids are
now running the country
and they don't have a clue what it took
to pay the price of building this thing
up to where it's at today anyways that's
just my idea and then what happens when
you got money that you never earned you
easily give it away you don't care you
give it away to anybody and everybody so
we're not we're not diligent with the
amount of work people did prior to us to
get america to where it's at today
and the arrogance of thinking you'll
never fall
i mean you know you've seen stories like
that in the military you've seen stories
like yesterday you know florida state's
playing louisiana lsu right
uh 24-17 guy catches the ball he fumbles
it florida state gets it they're about
to score a touchdown they fumble the
ball
lsu comes back they throw a touchdown
they're about to do uh
what do you call it the did you see it
or no i didn't say anything dude so so
so florida state is up 24-17 lsu is
about to receive the ball
the guy that receives the palm the
kickoff or the punt fumbles it florida
state gets it on the 10-yard line
they score touchdown apparently then
there's a flag they come back they're
about to score another touchdown the guy
fumbles the ball on three yard line lsu
gets it back they take it ball they
score a touchdown they're about to kick
the what do you call it the one point
extra point to tie it misses the point
game's over zero seconds left on the
clock florida state's win 24-23 the
arrogance of thinking we have it because
we're this you know
uh we don't think it'll happen to
america the level of paranoia i don't
think it's high
and the people running it are very
reckless with the way they're spending
money and it should be deeply concerning
to a lot of people that's my thoughts i
mean we're spending money spending
sending money to everybody trying to
save up sales uh solve everyone's
problems and we're not teaching
hey guy
life is hard get a damn job
but you don't know how hard life is i
believe me
it's very very hard but it's not 1 1 000
of how hard it was in 1776.
it's not one 100 000 of our heart was
your heart today is a joke
a 200 years ago so stop pitching stop
whining stop feeling sorry for yourself
and more importantly
the leaders at the top stop it's one of
the hardest things to do as a leader one
of the hardest things to do as a leader
is to feel bad and guilty for the amount
of work somebody else has to do like you
did
to get to the point where you feel
guilty you want to help them get it in
an easier way they got to pay the damn
price and we're in a place right now
where we feel sorry for everybody it's a
very weak leadership position because
you don't have a backbone that's not
real leadership real leadership is to
empower tell people we believe in you
and challenging them and willing to
stand aside even though they may
criticize you demonize you and hate you
a little bit and you're going to say i
want to be okay because long term you're
going to be independent you're not going
to need me long term the job of a father
isn't to keep the son dependent to the
father for his rest of his life the job
of a father is to keep the kid
independent that one day son doesn't
need him so when their daddy's dead son
says oh my gosh my dad raised me well
we're not thinking about those things
today we're just thinking about here's
another 200 billion dollars do whatever
you want to do with it with a bunch of
games and i think it's a very weak
leadership and it's concerning
well you're in a unique position to be
able to say that you see see man i can
try and make those points because i've
been in public office and i've seen it
and i've had the incredible benefit of
being able to study history and meet
people and talk and discuss and all the
rest of it but in the end
i've not known the alternative
personally you have which is why what
you say is so powerful
and why you can render such a service if
i may say so
when you say things like that when
you're when you bring us back to reality
you've seen the option
[Music]
you've seen people yesterday yesterday
we have a couple guys at the house two
nights ago i mean yesterday it's on
midnight i'm talking to these two
iranians i said tell your story i
haven't told anybody what's that
three i'm living in plano so four years
ago i go to my dad so i gotta talk to i
don't want you telling anything to jen
what's that
i i'm gonna go to iran for a week you
know you're not going to iran four weeks
i'm going to iran for a week
i'm not telling anybody i have to go to
iran why
i have to go to iran i have to go see
iran where i was raised i want to see it
i'm yearning for it right
okay i bought a whole chat and jam
hospital and all these places and he's
like no you're not going to iran's
episode i'm telling you i'm going to
iran for a week i just want to go see
this place because i want to take my
kids to iran one day i want to go see it
first and then when these guys are
grown-ups i want to take them to rome
one day anyways long story short letters
come in my sister shows me something
and he's able to persuade me not to go
we're running a company it's not fair
you got kids you got wife you got
companies people are relying anyways
obviously i didn't go to iran for the
one week i was going to keep a low key
and then boom i was going to go and come
back you have no idea how bad i want to
go back iran and see what iran is like
you know i want to see what happened
there here's a great nation with a rich
history that lost it all because of
extremism and not paying attention to
the value of freedom and then in america
which the greatest country in the world
hands down the greatest country in
the world the idea that accelerated and
grew at a pace that no other country in
mankind has ever grown
and here we are apologizing for it how
weird is that
when have you ever heard a team win
first place and apologize to second
place for whooping their asses i've
never heard of that before have you
heard about that like have you heard tom
brady saying afterwards listen i'm so
sorry we beat you
i'm so sorry our ideas and plays are
just better than yours i'm so apologetic
can you see michael jordan going to the
lakers and saying we're going to
you know the the phoenix suns hey
barclay i'm so sorry i beat you man
really makes me feel so bad no we're a
leader this is what we are comes with
pressure comes with a lot of animosity
from others because they don't like the
fact that they lost but at the same time
don't put in their face
be a humble winner be a humble number
one and keep the standards high we have
a standard issue and unfortunately
i've said this numerous times with high
standards today you're not going to get
elected the only way to get elected
today
is with low standards with today's
policies to to inject the concept of
high standards i believe into men and
women of a nation
[Music]
you need the support of education you
need the support of universities you
need the support of you need you need
the support of a lot of people to get it
to say
you're right the way we can resurrect
what we once had we all need to buy into
high standards low excuses
responsibility reliability pride in our
nation pride in our last name pride in
the fact that i'm i'm an immigrant i
came from iran and even though i'm made
in you know i'm born in iran i'm made in
america i got pride for my blood but i
love the country that gave me this
freedom that message today resonates
with a percentage the other percentage
sister and say you're arrogant i can't
believe you're saying this again this
doesn't mean feel sorry for me this
message is not going to sell this just
mean say it anyways
don't be afraid if you're losing certain
people sell high standards we're not
selling high standards we're selling low
standards today we're selling feel sorry
for me today we're selling victimhood
today 100 so so the only answer to
cancel culture is courage culture
tell the truth well i think what you're
talking about is on the table there's a
famous phrase they'll just dumb it down
it's you got to take the good with the
bad
and the problem was with this you know
wokism leftism
victim mentality is that they want to
burn the whole thing down and dismiss
all the good that's been done here in
america well they did this and oh they
did that and i'm gonna it's not fair
it's like
well where do you want to go buddy
because you're living in this country
complaining about this country where
would you like to go it only cost 500
bucks to get a ticket to go anywhere
else
go someplace else so that is what is so
upsetting to me it's like you're you're
a 100 believer in capitalism right pat
i'm i'm
100 okay however you are willing to say
maybe there's some areas that can be
fixed but you're a capitalist
fair enough i'm i mean i'm in the i mean
i'm all about incentives drive the right
behavior okay so whoever controls the
incentives will produce the right
behavior so
if the incentives today are controlled
by a biden they produce the wrong
behavior that's what i believe in okay
but overall capitalism you agree with it
but it's not it what do they say is it's
not perfect but it's the best system
we've ever seen everything else is
secondary to it but it's not perfect you
know what what i would use though it's
natural
capitalism it's a hundred percent
natural
rather than forced upon you collectivism
to me capitalism one day when some
people apologize for it and we we all
say it because somebody else said it
which is what it's not perfect was the
best thing we got [ __ ] it's it's
natural it's it's you
we're naturally born capitalist
we are capitalists
it doesn't matter what you think about
we're capitalist everybody's a
capitalist even the socialist is a
capitalist you know even the communist
is a capitalist the communist is so
competitive that he wants you to believe
his argument is the best the only
difference between the capitalist and
the communist is the communist wants to
eliminate a competitor the capitalist
wants to have a competitor he just wants
to compete against the competitor to see
if he can make it or not one is trying
to eliminate the other one wants to
compete
allow me to see if i can do a better job
okay capitalism doesn't work when
bureaucrats and aristocrats show up but
till then it's a great system what about
the socialists who's tweeting about
capitalism from their iphone yeah i
always find that ironic that goes back
to the whole concept where even they've
sold you that trickle down didn't work
oh so we're gonna go back to that of
course we are they've sold you a smart
guy that trickle down doesn't work
because they've say
the power of affirmation saying it so
many times until smart people like you
say maybe they're right so trickle down
worked that's what you're saying
it's it's not about trickle down works
man incentives work the only different
do you know you know i would do it
differently here's how we do differently
i would tax those that don't bring value
to the economy
but they don't have any money to be
taxed it doesn't matter i'm i'm taxing
you higher
the more value you it should be the
other way around commissions paid higher
to those that perform higher
you don't say hey wait what did you do
you did 200 000 last month payment lower
pays commission what sales organization
ever does that hold on i do have to say
something because you came up with an
idea a few months ago that i fully
agreed with which is what you shouldn't
tax anybody that's making less than 50
grand i'm totally okay with that part i
said that part but if you're but that's
different from what you're saying
once you go above that yeah then we
should tax people that produce more less
the more you produce you should pay less
taxes so that's the antithesis of the
progressive tax system yes so that's the
trickle down that you're saying with
that but my philosophies
i need a new country to run this
philosophy we would never work in
america
they would never buy into what i'm
saying to you yeah
in australia so ultimately what i'm
saying is there's especially on the left
i mean you might have even mentioned
something on the right uh america we you
know when we are not doing it right we
need to start over the 16 19 woke ism
these are people who are born and raised
in america you never hear immigrants
who have moved here and have fled other
countries saying america they're not
doing it right they're
in line to freaking get here in
australia is there is there that
woke-ism on the left that's basically
saying
you know everything that happened with
aboriginal people everything that
happened when you're criminal like
what's that uh parallel is well it's
very powerful it's common to the western
world that's the point um a lot of it of
course came out of the left bank and
intellectualism in france and i noticed
president macron the other day said
we've exported it we don't want it back
or was the fact the americans picking up
some of these mad ideas but it's no
different in our countries i mean for
heaven's sake there's an attempt in
edinburgh and scotland at the moment to
tear down the statue of livingston
livingston was a scot
who became one of the leading
abolitionists fighting the slave trade
you know why they want a terry statue
down because the age of 10 he worked in
a cotton mill and some of the cotton
might have been produced by slave milk
slave owners
therefore he should be torn down now
first question is what sort of society
how how
you know to judge him when he was a 10
year old had to go out to work to get a
bit of bread for i suppose for his
probably widowed mother or whatever what
years was this
yeah okay but he was part of the great
abolitionist movement in the uk which
was the leading empire of the day and un
inconveniently it was a bunch of you
know wealthy white privileged males
often christian who fought slavery they
know they're meant to be the cause of
all the problem now white wealthy
privileged males they're they're the
problem so all of that stuff is alive
and well but what i would i'd go back to
a point we made earlier about if if
if capitalism is to work well because
what capitalism does it captures
the genius
of you know however many billions of
minds there are making individual
decisions about what's in their own best
interests
but it needs to have happen in some sort
of context of a moral framework so
government's got to set some rules you
know and you've got to have ways of
capturing people who really do the wrong
thing so you want a mixed economy but
the other point is it comes down a lot
to whether your culture is one that's a
high trust culture
and i'll give you a very simple example
in australia we had the australian
mutual providence society
you know financial institution it
started out as its name implies a
providence society for the less well-off
insurance for
widows you know if they lost their
husbands so they could feed their
children and so forth it grew into one
of our major financial institutions two
or three years ago we had a royal
commission of inquiry into the banking
and financial sector it emerged that a
lot of these people these banks couldn't
be trusted they hadn't been behaving the
way people thought they should have it
was a bit overplayed there was still a
lot of ethical behavior i'd want to say
that to anyone listening there were many
bankers who did the right thing but the
amp
came out of it utterly disgraced it went
from
uh our leading historian said the most
trusted institution in australia after
the churches when it was set up in the
1840s the one where you couldn't put
your buck and trust that it was safe and
the australian people completely lost
confidence in it it was all about its
charter the people who set it up the
fact that they were committed to
creating wealth not just for their own
comfort but for the benefit of others
uh and it was seen to be such it was
trusted so it comes back it's not just
trusting our politicians you need it in
you know your business sector you need
it in your courts you need it in your
education system when trust breaks down
freedom
disappears because you know the three of
us are here four of us here in this room
as we met one of the questions in our
minds was can i trust this person if we
trust each other we can have a
cooperative agreement and discussion if
we don't we're looking to think gee i
need some security i'm going to back off
freedom's less important
than
security if trust breaks down you see
where i'm going yeah
so once you decry the need to trust once
you breed up cynicism once you breed up
suspicion of the other person it goes
back to worm
i hope you'll forgive me for saying this
as somebody from the other side of the
world but i'm so distressed by the tone
and the words of the attack that your
president launched that can only be seen
as an
attack on so many millions of his fellow
americans i just thought it was just
again yeah this is the famous speech
you're all talking about here now where
we just he he hardened down presumed
beyond poll numbers designed to get
democrat voters out we don't do that in
australia because voting is compulsory
if it wasn't we'd have the same problem
as you half people who wouldn't turn up
to vote and even less than half of young
people compulsory meaning mandatory yeah
in australia you have to vote you have
to vote if you're 18 or older yep you do
have to you have to and what do you find
if you don't vote yeah you are not
heavily but you are fined
wow you have to register and you have to
vote and as you think that is a good
thing uh it's a mixed thing uh the prime
minister i served with doesn't believe
in it i used not to i think i do now
because i think the horrors of trying to
get people out to vote
the bribery the corruption no i can't
say bribery corruption but the
extraordinary things that happen to try
and get your vote your base out
to try and appeal to your base rather
than the national interest you know
what's good for the country
i think compulsory the way we have it is
probably the lesser
of the problematic approaches well i
wouldn't die in a ditch over it but i
think on balance i come out i know you
have strong feelings on this compulsory
voting i know you do because you've you
your idea on voting was actually very
unique i've never heard anybody come up
with the idea that you had you know what
i'm talking about right i think you got
to earn the right to vote right same way
you live in a house and kids don't get a
chance to vote for what they're doing
until they're contributing to the house
if you're contributing to the house
you've earned the right to vote if
you're contributing to society you got
to earn the right to vote
i i i'm more comfortable with a 14 year
old kid who's paid 3 000 in taxes to
have the right to vote and the 25 year
old kid
who's never paid a nickel in taxes he
should not vote so it shouldn't be based
on age it should be based on
who's contributed to society
my my system of again it's not a popular
people would lose their minds if i pitch
my well i'm voting i'm sure there's
people listening to me like pat you're
out of control it's okay i'm not i'm not
sitting here trying to make friends i
didn't create this podcast to say i need
five more friends in my life i created
this podcast to see if you
enjoyed you disagree with it tell me i'm
you know you totally have no clue what
you're talking about fine i'll receive
it or
you know there's a point to it but you
know you said something
uh when you're telling the whole history
of what they're trying to do with that
man who worked at a cotton uh
livingston livingston and livingston of
africa yeah living son of africa he
cared about he really cared
about setting
africans free who would he be in america
like if you were to make a comparison to
someone
in our history who would that be in
america oh you i don't know you're the
figures because they were there they're
decried now but who would have been a
great american um harriet beecher stowe
i don't know that's a bit of a wild
pluck but somebody who really went out
against the grain of the day
and said look these are people of equal
worth and dignity to us
lincoln a lincoln without a president
living yeah yeah yeah of that ilk
yeah and he he worked with william
wilberforce who my political hero
william wilberforce inherited a vast
fortune he went into parliament at the
age of 21 he was seen as a future prime
minister in britain which in those days
was the leading empire in the world
you know and he went underwent the sort
of extraordinary um you know sort of
christian opening of his eyes and he
decided that slavery was evil and he
started actually campaign on the basis
their slogan was am i am i not a man and
a brother
and wedgewood pottery you've heard of
wedwood pottery the first it's a famous
english pottery company josiah wedgwood
he struck the first political pamphlet
if you like a whole series of actual
pieces of pottery dishes and what have
you and they had this incredibly
beautiful picture
of
an african man looking up pleadingly and
the slogan underneath am i not a man and
a brother now that was revolutionary
stuff
and here are these people privileged
white males who are apparently at the
heart of every problem you could ever
imagine saying
we've got this wrong and they took
denigration they were cancer subject to
cancer culture like nothing else the
king cut wouldn't talk that's an english
expression wilberforce was cut by the
king which in english society as a
parliamentarian meant that you were
nobody for his position on all this and
eventually
they won
they won
and then britain sent ships out onto the
high seas british navy ships
to stop other countries
trading in human beings the misery of
human beings
well you you used a term that i've never
really heard before you said
destatification
the uh the statueing de-statute pulling
statues down yeah and i mean this my
mind went to what was happening during
2020 in covid
and i remember a very specific story
there's a difference between a lincoln
and a thomas jefferson and our friend uh
what's his what's his name lucius
trescott iii
and the confederacy you know robert e
lee stonewall jackson and i remember
this was one of our first podcasts when
we first started this thing and two plus
years ago
should confederate statues be removed
and what should we do with them and i
you know pat to his point very emotional
at the time adam over here i'm like take
them all down remove them they shouldn't
be here they're traders confederates get
them out of here and i was very
emotional and vocal about it and then i
started seeing what was happening
and then all of a sudden slippery slope
let's remove lincoln
let's remove jefferson and say whoa oh
guys yeah they want to get rid of
churchill because he was a racist hang
on the bloke he defeated was something
of a race yeah that guy hitler was
pretty bad but you know what i came you
know not everything's black and white
it's great essentially what i
came to the premise of is yeah those
confederate statues
if i had to say would be moved into a
museum
you want to understand about the
confederacy
teach what happened you can't just watch
everything i get that because for
example i mean i i'd go out to wanda and
join a de-staturing movement if somebody
wanted to put one up to a i think you
called him adolf we call him adolf
hitler
i'd want to i'd want to pull it down
of course but on the other hand of it
were
you know somebody who had a mixed record
yeah you know uh we've had one pulled
down in australia he had a mixed record
um he did no doubt about it but he did
good things as well as bad things you
know you got to take the good with the
bad john you know an english writer
sorry if i'm sounding like an englishman
now but um
you know the rhodes you've all heard of
road scholarships and he was a south
african mixed record he did some bad
things he did some terrific things and
some other people he's trained up with
his money scents have done fantastic
they wanted to pull his statue down and
a british writer matthew paris said no
no no leave it there
put off statue of the king of the zulus
opposite him on the other side of the
street and tell both sides of the story
and then we'll all learn something
you remember that lucious truscott your
buddy one of my favorite interviews of
all time now you but you know what it is
you know as the saying goes he who
controls the president controls the past
absolutely and he who controls the past
controls the future so absolutely people
can and i think this is george orwell i
i want to say he said from the 84 book
or something so whoever's controlling
the present is kind of telling people
what happened in the past and you got to
be kind of careful with that so
uh the only way for us to remove all
these statues and all these different
people you know all you're saying is
you're afraid of people learning about
the history of what happened in the past
if i really want to teach my kids
leadership they're eventually going to
be reading about this guy
hitler they have to they've already read
about him they've already studied about
it they started reading about him at 7-8
years old you have to know that
evil does exist in regards to leaders
there's some leaders that are willing to
go out there and you have to be ready
for it you have to be strong for it so
if you want to understand capitalism you
have to read
both wealth of nations you have to study
thomas soul and milton friedman but you
also have to read
communist manifesto you have to read it
because you can't read one without the
other you have to read and say i see
what the argument he's making so if we
eliminate these all we're saying is
let's dumb down the people because we
can't handle
people in the past who
either were flawed either it's you know
something bad but god forbid we learn
about the true history of it
uh it's it's a form of copping out and
being weak but let's let's talk about
bite and speech you know a couple
comments was made about it one
when trump heard his speech by the way
can you pull up the picture
i i who came up with the setting though
did you see the setting it's very high
did you watch the entire speech
have you listened to the entire speech
no i've seen parts have you have you
listened to the whole thing yet or no no
not okay so i was watching this thing
and
you know
it's it's a very weird speech very very
and the reason why it's a weird speech
is the following reason so for example
how many times did trump give speeches
when he was a president
how many times was he on camera talking
a lot all the time yeah daily that guy
was a day how many times is he on camera
talking giving speeches
once every three three or six months i'm
actually i'm not being sarcastic how
often is he doing that i mean he gives
prep press briefings but no like this is
not very often this is not but trump was
doing these types of things all the time
right so if you're not doing this that
often that's part of your strategy where
your own team says joe we don't want you
to give a lot of speeches when you do
get them you have to figure out a way to
capitalize on these moments i thought it
was a
missed opportunity it was very divisive
it was very
you know uh
the 74 million people you have to be
careful with them those marines were
standing behind them people were upset
about the red light that just doesn't
look good period that just doesn't look
the way they did the
setting but aside from that here's what
trump said trump hits back at biden in
his first rally since fbi ray danger to
our democracy comes from the radical
left not the radical right
um he shot back at uh at him the save
america event marked trump's first rally
since the fbi raid his uh hit his home
august 8 trump focused a large portion
of his speech on the corruption and
extremism of the democratic party
republicans in the medical movement are
not the ones
trying to undermine our democracy we are
the ones trying to save our democracy
the danger to our democracy comes from
the radical left not the right and so he
gives that speech then
uh nikki haley goes out there and says
um
where's the nikki haley's speech there's
something about what nikki haley said i
thought i had it here she thought it was
very
uh what's the word she used
condescending condescending message that
was through the most condescending
uh the most condescending speech ever
given president president of my lifetime
president of all of our lifetime given a
message that's condescending that joe
rogan slammed the blood red dark
background of biden speech he reacted
friday to the background
uh speech to host the spot about joe
rogan's one of the podcasts
you know he couldn't believe what the
background was like you know what
imagine thinking this was a good idea
it's what joe rogan said imagine
thinking this was a good idea so
you know with the current state you saw
this i don't know you said you didn't
see this you saw bits of it bits and
pieces of it and obviously you had some
thoughts about it is there anything else
you want to say when you saw the speech
like did you see that speech saying
there was ten percent of it that was
good it was you know this part of it
that was good because one party is
talking mega the other part is i'm not
just the president for the democrats i'm
a democrat president for the left and
the right and the middle i want to be
the president for everybody you can't
say that but at the same time you take
shots
yeah and organization again
i do i want to be respectful of american
americans so i can only say i was just
personally deeply distressed as an
observer from the other side of the
world as i see america as the leader of
the free world and critical to our
future and i i loathe division i do i
hate the idea of of of division so what
i saw was yes some appeal to some higher
ideals
but that was to sort of almost set up
the attack on
people who have a different set of
opinions is apparently being responsible
for smashing those ideals
rather than to say how can we sit down
and talk through
and recommit to those ideas i found
myself thinking this is a surprisingly
fluent speech because i haven't seen a
lot of fluent species you know i usually
see the cards or we hear him repeating
bits that are on the auto q a genuine
question would he have had some sort of
device there for auto q's screens in
front because it was quite fluent yeah i
think you make a great point here and
i'm going to give a couple different
perspectives here
i hear so many people basically saying
joe biden can't speak anymore
okay he's got dementia he can't even get
words out of his mouth he was pretty
clear for an hour it pre people
understood what he was saying it's 22
minutes okay so a half hour almost the
point is he gave a long speech so on one
side of things people are saying he
can't speak he's in the basement hiding
well he's out there um i don't think it
was necessarily a
speech that will live in infamy however
this is the thing that he's missing
donald trump and the mag of republicans
are a threat to the very soul of this
country okay
magga is the new republican party
okay what's donald trump's approval
ratings within the republican party
ninety percent tyler you would know this
it's close to 90 okay so
the republican party
that it that we knew that george w bush
previous republican dick cheney
you know that establishment that doesn't
exist anymore that's gone but does the
republican party of truman and clinton
do democratic party of truman and
clinton exist anymore
arguably they would not be specifically
about the republicans
the the old republican guard does not
exist the list cheney's of the world
adam kinders of the world the dick
cheney's of the world the mitt romney's
of the world the george w bush
gone
this is trump's party
whether it's good or bad
he controls the party so what biden is
missing is quote unquote the mag of
republicans or the that is the new
republican party it's not a fringe
element of the republicans so your point
is that it really is an attack on a vast
number of that's what i'm saying is that
80 million people voted for
trump
and of that
of the republicans
75 million people is who we're talking
about here so it's a mixed messaging so
that's maybe what he i don't know
clearly somebody was telling him what to
say wrote to speech what have you but
that is the most that is what resonates
the most with me about this is that the
misunderstanding that the republican
party is now the maga party the previous
party is now gone the rhinos gone
you know when's the only time a speech
like this works
when you know for a fact you have a big
lead
you can't talk like this when you don't
have a lead he doesn't have a lead
you have to try to
show a different side
you can't talk like this when you don't
have a lead he does not have a lead so
it's got to come from a different angle
it's got to come from an angle to try to
win people over you know
when i when i left when i started out in
politics
my predecessor in my i think i don't
know what you'd call a district i think
but in my electorate he was a wise man a
very good man
and he said now but as you kick off john
there's something you need to understand
he said half the people who vote you
voted for you will love you
and half the people that voted for you
won't
they voted for you yeah and half the
people who didn't vote for you
will hate you but half of them will
actually think you're a very good person
don't
antagonize the people who did not vote
for you many of them will have different
perspectives and they may not have been
able to put your their tick against your
name but they're fine australians yes i
fully agree with them i agree and you
said this is what distressed me about
the speech as a former practice look i'm
just from a little country and i was
only the deputy i wasn't the president
of the united states but i look at it as
a really concerned
deeply committed uh the person when it
comes to democracy and freedom and i
think this guy is what he says is
words are bullets
and there are all those americans out
there who voted for
i just don't think trump was the problem
as people say
so much as the product of the problem if
you've got fellow americans who feel so
alienated so left behind
so
[Music]
um
dismissed by today's elites including we
were talking about capitalism
you know the the the the tech
billionaires are squinters who seem to
be quite contentious of little people
it's as though they're the problem they
want their plasma tvs and their jet skis
and their chevy suburbans and they're
the enemy of the part you know the
planet so while i get wealthier and i'm
not going to give up any of my lifestyle
and i'll get around the world to climate
claims conferences and i'll live in a
you know in a mansion and i'll have
several holiday houses scattered around
the world and i'm a global citizen
you people who by the way just happened
to feed me and keep the transportation
system working and educate my kids and
police the streets you're just scum
you're the enemy
that sort of contempt
is
extant in all of our countries i'm not
singling out the united states please
don't hear me say that i'm saying i
think it's a real problem for social
harmony and democracy depends upon
social harmony depends on trust it
depends on respect for the other person
when you have a debate it should be as
fierce as you like i mean i i've
listened with respect uh to what
patrick's saying in you know with with
with all crazy because so yeah i'm sorry
good keep going um and
you know we don't have to agree on
everything right but we can we're going
to have a fierce argument on the things
we might disagree on but in the end
we're fellow human beings
right and if we lose sight of that
and if some people are scum they're the
enemy and gay or the goddess earth or
whatever we start to paint them that way
no wonder they're going to hit out so
what's the commander-in-chief's job to
do make sure he's actually got his army
behind him
not a great slab of them
wanting to you know overturn the system
right and to your point i mean hillary
clinton learned this lesson the hard way
when she came out and said that half of
all republicans are what she would throw
into the basket of deplorables not a
good look to start talking [ __ ] about
your constituency
whether they vote for you or not to your
point half of people that vote for you
will like you and not like you so here's
here's a here's a question you had to
ask yourself
so imagine like you know how i don't
know what trump's record is when he
endorses you you win and when you don't
you lose by 37 your name is liz cheney
okay so the power of an endorsement from
trump is a lot of power
think about the guys that are getting
ready for midterms i'm talking everybody
else is like man i gotta i need him to
give a good speech
how many of them are sitting around
saying oh my god what is going to be the
value of a joe biden endorsement today
what the hell am i getting like i need
him to be better so i can get
more influence from your endorsement so
imagine joe biden comes you're running
somewhere yeah
i i endorse adam sosnick for you know
district this this that how much weight
does that have today so it's almost that
his speech
hurts others as well that are hoping for
him to give a speech to get that
endorsement i mean we're going to find
out we'll know we'll know in a couple
months here whether there's value to it
or not i hear you i'll also give a
different perspective
you know part of the problem that's
happening in the senate right now is
that they're putting out weak candidates
okay and and you know the house is
expected to flip but in the senate
they're expected to hold if you look at
numbers it's because the candidates are
weak
the pro and yes you are right that you
know trump i think went like 20-0 last
week so i'm like oh five and 17. okay
but there is a problem with that is that
all these people are just bowing at the
throne of trump and they're just
basically saying yeah sure i'll do
whatever you do you're doing that to
obama obama was the same way
not to this extent there's there's
definitely a a kneeling at the golden
calf about
an endorsement from obama for a democrat
was super valuable correct but not as
valuable as trump well then that just
means trump's better so it doesn't mean
that it's worse no it's just that
they're going to pander to him
yeah they pander to obama like what are
you talking about well i don't know are
we talking about like people didn't
pander to obama like what do you think
they're going to do obama's going to say
i'll help you but here's what you need
to yeah but that this means candidates
are just going to be as trumpy as
possible and just paired exactly like
candidates are going to be as obamay as
possible so what would have happened
what would have happened if um if donald
trump in response to that speech
had said in genuine tones of sorrow i am
so sorry that the president of the
united states feels this way
i'm so sorry that he misunderstands
that we believe in the american dream of
freedom we actually want to build a
cooperative nation we actually want to
say all americans matter yeah we want to
say that there are serious politicians
that's not what he stands for though
what would have happened
it's not it's not going to happen what's
going to happen if donald trump doesn't
tweet what's going to happen if donald
trump doesn't pick fights with people
that he isn't at peak fights with we
could we can have this wishful thinking
of trump but we know who trump is like
him or not he's not changing i'm raising
a hypothetical what had happened what
would have happened if he had actually
taken and what i'm saying is the
hypothetical is not even hypothesis it's
not even possible that's not trump's dna
he's a fighter and people love the fact
that he's a fighter and some people do
but they're always hot they're wise to
fight we know trump's uh mo he's he's a
fighter he's not going to come out and
try to unify you'll be in a long list of
people that have been trying to change
this guy yeah
okay well it was a hypothetical it leads
on to the second question i would like
to go down the hypothetical rabbit hole
but it's there's no hypotheticals with
the trump anymore we know what we're
getting can i ask a second question
on behalf of my fellow australians one
of the things that they most commonly
say to me
the question they ask how come
that america of 300 million people a
global leader
full of very very bright and capable
people who have done astounding things
in all walks of life i'm patting this
out a bit well that's that's the intent
behind the question on behalf of america
we thank you for the compliments
i'll take this on behalf of america mr
anderson the best of your best are they
are extraordinary just and the best of
your institutions they're mind-boggling
nobody else has matched them but the
question people ask is how come that
country
uh you know has put up two guys like
that as alternatives for the the
leadership of america i totally agree
where are the where are the
legendary americans this is the great
question of our time you're absolutely
right this is the great question of our
time so you were answering my aussie
question with an american question yes
high standards is not attractive high
standards and high expectations is not a
popular philosophy but but how come
because i made so many americans because
the leaders lost their backbone because
leaders started appeasing to others on
feeling
guilty for what it really took to win
and the better way is oh my gosh i have
to conform
and historically people eventually
conform
that's what most people eventually do
they conform very few people have a
backbone that they stay
forever it's not that many people
it's not hard to take away people's
backbone just tell them how special they
are give them a little bit of their
recognition you know whether it's a
nice place to live nice book that
becomes bestseller give them a nice
house nice car a nice relationship
accolades respect couple articles write
about them they'll conform very quickly
there's very few people that are
not turned on by those things they just
think that's part of their life and they
still keep their backbone
and history doesn't like people like
that but history desperately needs
people like that okay next question
i sat in a study a fellow i know and he
got some young americans for me from all
over the place in washington okay
and i looked at them i listened to them
i i saw the passion in their eyes the
intelligence and the decency and i
thought
what's gone wrong in our system so i'm
not going to single out america because
we've got the same problem what's gone
wrong in our system that these people
even if they wanted to have a go would
feel that there was no pathway they're
intelligent they're driven they
understand freedom they're committed to
it
they're ideal citizens the sort of thing
that the founding fathers recognized was
going to be needed in leadership and
which we're all saying we want
do we want it enough to make pathways
what's why can't they get through in
this country
because they can't in australia that's
what they tell me what's stopping those
young people from pursuing careers in
leadership
meaning in politics
i don't think they're
stopping i will say there's more younger
guys that are stepping up today
that are being inspired to go into
politics there's a lot of good strong
capitalist young guys the the bench is a
very very deep bench but
they're in their
mid to late 20s early 30s so it's about
another decade
there's going to be a very very massive
deep bench of new superstars coming up
with backbones
but it's going to take about a decade or
so for them to come and by the way
here's
here's here's the the part of that with
the with the backbone situation
on these guys coming up most people like
i had a conversation with a guy flew out
and i sat down with him and i said
listen i think you got to run for office
i think you got to run for governor and
i had a meeting with him and his wife
and you know and i told them why i think
you should run for office his wife says
tell me how bad it's going to be and i
said very bad they're going to come
after you they're going to come after
your kids they're going to come out to
your family they're going to come after
everything you've ever done
and some stuff's going to come out well
then that's why i said no but
you have to you have to understand that
none of us walk on water
like if people come after you and the
fear is that they're going to find
something in your uh in your what do you
call it in your skeleton they're going
to find some skeletons okay
go ahead find the skeletons in my closet
yeah matter of fact i'll give you a
couple other bones here's you forgot
about these two bring these two up as
well i'll do some research for you and
you can so now what hey so here's what
you guys learned officially you learn i
don't walk on water you'll learn i have
a past you learn to have issues you
learn i'm not perfect you learn all that
stuff now how about i spend a half a
million dollars to investigate your past
with your marriage your past with your
ex your past with your taxes your past
with this do you want me to do that how
about i spend those resources on you do
you want me to put that on you as well
no no no no no how about i fire some
investigators to follow you for the next
two months i have the money to do it how
about if i do it then they say well no
that's not fair that's this that's that
no then it just means you don't walk on
water i don't walk on water do you like
my policies great vote for me you don't
leave me the hell alone i'll go back to
my life but we can't be like
well what if they find out what i did
when i did this yeah what if we all find
out about what everybody did you know it
would be a very if if we all walked
around with all three biggest sins shown
above our forehead
we would be very disappointed with
people jonathan rabbi sax was a member
of the house of lords in england he
tragically died
quite recently but i did a podcast with
him and he said that no made the point
that no family no community no country
can work if you wash forgiveness out
and that's one of the great marks of the
viciousness and nastiness of our society
now we won't let bygones be bygones
and it doesn't work in your personal
life you know you're going to make a
mess somewhere in your marriage you're
going to do something wrong you've got
to say i'm sorry you're going to do it
with your kids you've got to say i'm
sorry most powerful moment with one of
my kids was and she was a very strong
personality little girl i said sorry one
day i said daddy did you say sorry i
said yeah i got that wrong
instant restoration you know um
and he made the point that our culture
now doesn't particularly the left this
nasty sensorious attitude that if you've
done one thing wrong that's it you're
cancelled you're on the way to the
guillotine
and i said well what happens what can
you hope for
if there's no forgiveness he said maybe
that people forget he said well that
doesn't work either because now social
media means they can bring up anything
from the past so maybe he had a point we
need to learn to recognize that none of
us are perfect and a little bit of
forgiveness goes a long way now that
doesn't mean you go live a reckless life
that doesn't mean you go live a hey
since i'm going to be forgiven i'm just
going to go be super reckless and do
whatever i want to do and do whoever i
want to do and you know be that kind of
a life that's also not the point my
point isn't that my point is
try to live a strong life
back it up with honor strong values
principles
loyalty dependability reliability all of
that stuff but at the same time
you're not going to be expecting
somebody to run that's going to be
walking on water i think we've got
plenty of people that should be running
that don't want to run are you following
what's going on in prague are you
following the story on what's going on
in prague or not you hear about it
already so tens of thousands of protests
in prague against czech government eu
and nato this is a u.s news story from
yesterday
an estimated 70 000 people protested in
prague against the czech government on
saturday calling on the ruling
coalition to do more to control the
soaring energy prices and voicing
oppositions of the eu and nato
organizers of the demonstration from a
number of far-right and fringe political
groups
including the communist party said the
central european nation should be
neutral
military and ensure direct con contracts
with gas suppliers including russia
police estimates to put the numbers of
protesters at around 70 000 by mid
afternoon
the aim of our uh
demonstration
is to demand change mainly in solving
the issue of energy prices especially
electricity and gas which will destroy
our economy this autumn event
co-organizer gerald havel told idnes
that cze news website the protest
uh uh was held at a day after the
government survived a no-confidence vote
amid opposition claims of inaction
against inflation and energy by the way
this is going on in uk this is going on
in europe uk prices are up 89
norway saying to charge a tesla today's
100 bucks just to charge a tesla
this is a real crisis that's going on in
europe yeah what are your thoughts on
this uh
well
how do you open this up this is
extraordinary i mean people are
genuinely worried about the planet about
climate change
on the other hand ill-devised policies
unrealistic
expectations of others naivety if you
like
placing our dependence on manufacturing
or energy sourcing or whatever from
regimes that are autocratic uh us
germany uh they put all their eggs in
the they are in the basket of trusting
the russians to supply them with energy
um
you then you've got people like the sri
lankans who said we'll be purer than
pure and will phase out
or artificial fertilizers because it's a
major emitter and now their people are
starving and writing in the streets
we've got a massive problem this is a
real issue this is this is really good
time if badly designed policy will lead
to massive political unrest everywhere
and if we're not careful it's going to
do something else
we will weaken our own economies
massively
whilst we make the autocratic regimes
stronger yeah
so then this goes back to
did we do the right thing to get in the
way nato constantly trying to get
ukraine to
be a part of it to go against what putin
was asking for because here's
here's what we just said this is a new
york post story europe's energy fears
mount as russia keeps its gas pipeline
closed that's right the planned
reopening of russia's main gas pipeline
to germany was halted saturday after
stadium energy from
gaspron uh said it found an oil leak in
a turbine of north stream one deepening
fears of a winter energy crisis
throughout europe the announcement
fueled
accusations that russia seeking to
weaponize its sway over the world energy
market which would you be surprised i
wouldn't be this was in this was
predictable
and it was predicted former secretary
mike pompeo wrote on saturday i told you
so tweet i warned germany not to rely on
russian energy energy security is
national security which is why we must
reign our energy independence president
zielinski of ukraine also took to social
media to condemn the development when a
state turns energy poverty or hunger
into a weapon it harms everyone in the
world yeah well i mean these are these
are the ripple effects of some decisions
that you make you're gonna piss off
putin and you can play this game two
huge issues here for western societies
the first is naivety
we've got to stop leaders especially
should not be naive
whether it's the chinese saying no we
won't militarize the south china seas
and we say oh well you're nice people
you won't or what did they do
they did it you know in the middle east
don't cross this red line we cross the
red line what happens
naivety
is inexcusable in leadership
that's the first point the second point
is the massive dishonesty that pretends
you can have your cake and you eat it
too we don't have the technologies yet
to move to renewables and net zero we
have neither a political nor a
technological pathway to net zero by
2050. now i happen to believe i i'm not
a climate change denier i believe we
need to take these things seriously but
i think we'll utterly if we abandon our
humanity and firm in terms of feeding
people if we hand over control of the
global architecture to the forces of
darkness the rules-based international
system that the americans put in place i
mean the west put in place as the
victors after 1945 but the americans
drove and have upheld ever since
if we're going to break those what we'll
actually do by not being honest with
ourselves about the real policy options
before us the real choices that have to
be made
we'll do the very thing i've touched on
here the the very wealthy the people
pushing all this stuff leaning on
governments save gaia i don't know do
you have that expression here it's an
old roman thing you know the the
environment god earth is god
mother earth now we all want a safeguard
i don't know too many people who want to
damage gaia but there are other things
that go with it and you have to be
honest with people and if you're going
to have all the tech billionaires and
all those people who've become so
staggeringly wealthy telling governments
that you've absolutely got to force
everybody to buy a tesla and you've got
to you know
make them do all of these things in the
name of climate change without
explaining the cost
you're setting yourself up for the very
destruction of a trust-based political
system like democracy john question for
you this may not even have anything to
do what we just talked about but maybe a
little bit during the covet lockdowns
when they did what they did and a lot of
the folks in australia couldn't say
anything they couldn't do anything
would it would anything have changed if
they
the 1996 gun buybacks that they did
where they got a million of it would
they still have been able to push the
people the way they did if
the australian people had the guns and
it wasn't the way it was because you
know in america one of the conversations
right now is
you got some candidates that are talking
about buybacks as well
would it have made a difference do you
know i i genuinely don't think so i'd
have to think longer and harder about it
yeah but i genuinely don't think so
i think something else has happened
uh particularly in our education system
that has made
people as i say i don't think we can
underestimate the comfort that we've
lived in and the way it's satiated us
and we've thought it you've touched on
it
and we haven't been alert to the
subversion
of our core foundational beliefs the
ones that underpin freedom
and individualism
as they've been eroded and we haven't
understood what that's done to our
children
and as our children of age
come through the system
our society
and i i i'll tell you what i do think i
think in australia today and some of my
fellow australians would might disagree
or think i'm being too optimistic i
think a bit like china you've had a
giant wake-up call and people are
becoming much more realistic and i don't
think governments in australia will try
to lock people down like that again you
don't think so no i don't why not
i think
the australian people started to say you
say they didn't have a voice i think it
started to show up in the political
parties research and so forth that
australians were starting to say hang on
this is over the top they got there
before the politicians did this is not
working we've got to open up our economy
we've got to go back to jobs
i don't say it's been a completely
healthy recovery it hasn't we've still
got too many people who don't want to go
to work
we've got
unbelievable levels of stress with
people trying to find enough workers is
the irony it's very different to the
previous time we had inflation breaking
out because he had high unemployment
we've got almost no one unemployed in
australia at the moment it's incredible
and you've got very high employment here
too i see you know driving around here
your suburbs the shops have got we're
hiring now signs out i don't know how
common that was but in australia i
haven't seen that for 20 30 40 years no
one's talking about the fact that
unemployment just hit
three and a half percent which was
basically the 50-year low where trump
basically got it to
uh in 2018 so unemployment i mean we're
not talking about how high inflation is
in consumer price index
what happens to the wage levels as
interest rates go up and the other worry
i have is because nobody's talked about
budgets you've got a that's what a 30
trillion dollar public sector debt in
australia in america
what happens when the interest rates
start to rise the cost of servicing that
what's that going to mean for the other
things government do what's it going to
mean from happening you know what's it
mean for you defense budget what does it
mean for your welfare budget because
actually people get the wrong idea about
america your welfare expenditure is
actually very high now
you write a lot of checks for welfare in
this country
it doesn't seem like it's slowing down
anytime soon
uh anyways gang this has been two hours
uh i hope you've enjoyed this as much as
we have uh john appreciate you for
coming out all the way from australia
you came out and paid your visits to us
you know all over the place
uh uh folks if you have not yet
subscribed to john's podcast
he's got a youtube channel it's a very
different perspective it's a perspective
that we need to hear today he interviews
a lot of different personalities jordan
peterson's there i thought i saw a
pitching hitchens brother on is that
yeah he's very interesting dave rubin
dave rubin a lot of different
personalities that i've been on but uh
we're going to put the link below title
if we can put the link below in the chat
as well as in the description so people
can go out there and subscribe again
john anderson conversations
go uh click subscribe to his podcast and
once again john thank you so much for
coming out and being a guest on the
podcast here i'm surprised you wanted me
but i'm very honored and i really
enjoyed it i've enjoyed it way more than
you've enjoyed it again learning from
somebody like you from your perspective
sometimes allows us to see our blind
spots on what we're missing here so
appreciate your wisdom thank you it's
been a great joy
take care everybody i don't think we're
doing a podcast this week we got some
special surprises that we'll be
announcing to you very soon that you're
not going to like you kind of kind of
love maybe some of you guys are going to
hate it many of you are going to love it
we'll be back next week stay tuned bye
bye bye bye bye
you